I'm thinking of him as Chicago tea party
in July are you capitalist I want to
choke the lake michigan I'm gonna start
organized hey there at Stan haste /
reason TV I'm hanging on Lafayette Park
the site of the tea party protest in
Washington DC and I'm basically here to
just ask people questions and see why
they came out
so why'd you come out today I just
wanted to be one of the many voices in
opposition of the runaway spending this
happening in Congress right now just a
protest on the out of hand spending we
wanted to teach him a lesson about
standing up for what we believe standing
up for our country and our freedom
because I am fed up with the corruption
in Washington they are ripping out the
foundation of our economy with these
taxes you gotta cut down on the size of
government we gotta cut put money back
in the hands of the people who earn it I
stop spreading well because I believe
that we're being overtaxed we're being
over-regulating what would you do if you
were president you knighted States law
what I would try to do is live within
the budget by cutting government and and
waste and abuse lower taxes on the
working man let the economy get back to
normal on its own people know best how
to spend their own money I die I would
have to cut spending like I'm doing in
my own house very first thing i would do
is cut taxes i would i would cut taxes
dramatically which would put money
directly back in people's pockets they
could then go buy products which would
spur businesses like there are people
losing their jobs what do you guys tell
people who are losing their day there's
no question we're in tough economic
times absolutely the the message here
though is is that government
intervention is not the solution it's
lower taxes a lower corporate tax rate
we'd have less jobs going overseas if
the markets correct themselves in
recessions it's painful it's not pretty
but
they do we've had to relocate to move to
where the jobs are that's what I would
recommend though the message is is that
the American people are earned ingenious
people they are creative they are very
very good at creating their own
businesses they can control their own
fate oh that's what that's say it it's
scary because that's the main thing that
I think people identify themselves by
their job and when they don't have one
they feel lost and I feel sorry for him
to raise the the taxes on capital gains
and on businesses will hurt businesses
and so they won't be hiring anytime soon
I've lost my job before my father's lost
his job before the everyone has picked
up you know re-educated themselves or
taking on a job that they're not they
think it might be too good for what it
gets a flip burgers wall flip when we
have to dig ditches dig ditches do
whatever you have to do to get back up
under your own power without the
government's intervention and serve as
libertarians don't necessarily always
have a good record of turning out and
testing but when you get something like
this it really gets folks fired up and
you saw it here today we had almost 300
people here today and it's just
beginning
you